you've dovetailed into all these
different things kind of naturally and
artistically and by accident like you're
saying you had SNL but you were a punk
musician yeah and a there isn't a segue
from punk music to no it is it does feel
kind of accidental everything right from
film making to Serious to yeah you just
kind of say yes to a lot of stuff and
then something works out but it's how
did the people that knew you as a punk
how did how did comedy come how did any
funny come out of Music in 1998 I
started making videos of me interviewing
bands uh as different characters and
that's the sort of that got me into
comedy really what was a and I and I
made a friend of mine edited it and I
would give them away as VHS tapes are
they on YouTube yeah and what is it what
is that it's called Fred armon's guide
to music and South by
Southwest oh you went was it like a
prank thing I remember you kind of did
they know that you were being funny or
some and some didn't I remember watching
that and thinking it was like a hidden
camera thing like you weren't a real
like I wasn't a real like I pretended to
be a German journalist right and then
some of them didn't know I wasn't really
German but that was before s Sasha Baron
Cohen it was but it's that kind of thing
wasn't it where you know it was similar
to there was a British comedian named
Dennis pennis who was doing stuff like
that Dennis pennis yeah wow I didn't
know yeah let's see this even a moment
from this from uh South by Southwest
South by Southwest this is so you're
saying some did know and some didn't
know yeah some of them I were musicians
who I was already friends
with wow you guys are you guys have a
good research
Department hello there I'm Fred I'm in
Austin Texas right now for something
called the South by Southwest music
convention it's an annual convention in
which national touring bands booking
agents managers and record label
Executives meet hey can I can I borrow
your
[Music]
microphone why are you here in um I came
to South by Southwest with MTV doing
some interviews that's Janine Garo you
must have known her you didn't know her
that's the first time I met her but she
knew I was up to
something police work or FBI type things
for hurting people or arresting them
not usually no why is that a common
thing yes because uh in Germany
sometimes the police they come to door
and they want to find things out and so
they go to cities and they bring a
camera or whatever so I should be asking
you that you're the one with the camera
in the city oh she's she's with the
camera but but that's actually funny
let's I just thought that that was
really I remember watching that because
I'm a huge one of my favorite things and
the thing that inspired me to get into
comedy if I was going to get into comedy
was Allan fun and on candid oh yeah he
was great so any anything on YouTube
where I thought somebody was playing a
character and the other person didn't
know I remember watching that not I
didn't even until you told me today yeah
that that was you I didn't remember that
that was you but I remember a guy going
to the I remember seeing that yeah yeah
I don't remember seeing Janine Garo I
think I've seen some other she was
because she was there at the
festival
[Music]
he